hi I'm Eric Boston this is a breakdown
of the Walking Dead Season nine episode
9 the mid-season premiere yeah if you
used to watch our in-depth analyses of
episodes of The Walking Dead I'm sure it
was a bummer win starting season 9 we
couldn't keep covering the show each
week for a lot of reasons that I went
into in past videos especially when this
season 9 has been pretty good and I've
been wanting to talk to you guys about
it but the good folks from philo reached
out to a saying look we're gonna help
you out we've got a great way for fans
to stream the Walking Dead and we're
going to sponsor a relaunch of your
weekly breakdowns so thanks to Philo
we're back baby later I'll get into some
exciting details about Philo why you got
to jump on this and what you can expect
from this video series so stick around
at the end of the video for all that
let's dive into this Walking Dead
mid-season premiere some things that you
might have missed some deeper meaning
from the episode and where the second
half of season 9 might be headed spoiler
waiting if you haven't seen the episode
yet or if you're worried I might predict
anything to accurately and it'll ruin
your life so this episode opens with
some striking horror imagery the dead
body of Jesus shockingly killed by a
whisper and disguises of Walker in the
last episode there's a flash of
lightning with all this going down in a
spooky foggy Cemetery fair one Vincent
Price monologue - thriller this classic
horror imagery restored the show back to
its horror roots to accentuate the new
reason to fear Walker's some of them
might actually be people in disguise and
opening on dead jesus seems to be some
form of meta commentary by the show like
sure actor Tom Paine did admit that he
was getting bored in the role and was
ready to go
and by the way props to the skyper
hanging out as a limp rag doll for all
these shots but it's like this whole
episode loved the weird way Jesus is
dead sounded Jesus sister well
intentional or not this whole death of
spirituality fits in nicely with the way
the Walking Dead is pivoting to focus on
the science of the walkers last episode
was titled evolution a nod to Eugene's
theory that the walkers brains could be
evolving to relearn how to speak but of
course he was wrong and this episode is
a clarification on the season-long
biology lesson the latest unveiling in
the mystery of the walkers and that's
why this episodes titled adaptation see
evolution and adaptation are both
biological terms that are often confused
with each other unlike evolution which
takes millions of years across several
generations of species to take effect
adaptation refers to a single group of
organisms developing new behavioral
structures to help them survive so we're
not talking opposable thumbs and new
talking zombies we're talking
survivalist humans adapt into a zombie
world by a camouflage a tactic
foreshadowed all the way back in season
one when Rick used that meat poncho so
the walkers wouldn't smell him and then
he could walk amongst them but it's not
just the whisperers who are adapting
this episode after the cold open this
episode catches up with negan after
Gabriel forgot to lock the gate
negan was left with a doorway to freedom
but kind of like an issue 141 in the
comics Megan doesn't use this
opportunity to flee Alexandria forever
he actually ends up back in the cell
this episode is more like a prison
furlough for negan but this freedom is a
nightmare for the guy he gets hungry and
thirsty and sick walkers freak him out
his old palace is now in ruins even his
weapon is now hollow unlike the fearsome
bat that he used to wield negan is
essentially the institutional man that
we saw in the Shawshank Redemption
Walking Dead original showrunner Frank
Darabont's film that shares many
thematic parallels with the series like
the characters Brooks and red megan
hates it on the outside actually if you
look closely you'll notice that he
returns to the same clearing where he
killed Glenn and Abraham the very first
night that he met Rick and his crew
but now negan is the one brought to his
knees spewing his guts and while trying
to return to his leather daddy status
negan finds this creepy scene with a
family of mannequins arranged in a
domestic tableau with the father figure
as a human who blew his brains out it's
like this guy was Will Smith's character
and I am Legend a lonely man and the
post-apocalypse trying to recreate a
community with mannequins negan clearly
relates with this loneliness a former
husband and father himself who lost
everything and he'll never be able to
get it back the suicide echoes Brooks
the suicide from the Shawshank
Redemption a grim cautionary tale for
the new institutional man who's now on
the outside negan realizes that the only
thing close to family had was the Grimes
family now embodied by Judith Grimes she
bears the tokens of her relatives Carl's
sheriff hat and Rick's Colt Python
making juditha sort of grimes ghost the
compass that she lets negan keep
symbolizes her role as negan's moral
conscience and how Rick and Carl's
belief in Redemption and change is the
only way forward for negan we also get a
hint of how other characters have
adapted Michonne and
moreover never being able to bury rick
and michonne thanks Darrell for trying
to find him and thanking him for after
Darrell responds I'm putting his hand on
her shoulder so I'm pretty sure this is
a nod to that mysterious ex car that
both Michonne and Daryl have on their
lower backs Michael Cudlitz who actually
directed Episode seven of the season
tease that they got those scars through
some really effed up backstory that led
them to adapt to their even more closed
off mindsets that they currently have
there's a lot of different theories
about this my thinking right now is that
maybe Daryl and Michonne know that
Rick's survived the events of episode 5
and they know that he flew off to
another community with an remember this
is the community that's in the business
of trading people and they objectify
people into a and B categories maybe
there was some rescue attempt by Daryl
EMA shown that went horribly wrong and
it left them with these X scars but back
to the literal adapters of this episode
the whispers we meet Lydia the girl
Whisperer and daughter of alpha the
female leader who kidnaps alden and Luke
at the end of the episode loosely
adapted from the events of issues 134
and 135 in the comics Lydia gets
interrogated at the hilltop and spills
to the whisperers don't use names and
that they share a mutually protective
relationship with the walkers meanwhile
Henry serving the world's longest prison
sentence for underage drinking Bourne is
a budding romantic relationship with
Lydia now it looks like the show is
adapting the arc with Carl in the comics
he hooks up with Lydia she licks his eye
holes bit freaky but later we find out
that this might have been some
deliberate matchmaking by Daryl as the
two teenagers talk Daryl sits outside
and eavesdrops learning way more this
way than he ever could have by barking
at Lydia dragging her around remember it
was Daryl who made Henry stay in that
cell longer perhaps he was hoping that
the horny soft do you would get her to
squeal crazy this is a real game of
Thrones level tactics by Daryl who knows
that whether it's Eugene overhearing
Rosita's pregnancy by Siddiq or negan
overhearing gossip about Gabriel the
walls in these communities are not
soundproof also clever thinking in
general from Daryl this episode aiming
for the leg to test which walkers were
whispers headshot of course would just
kill him this guy wants to know but
coming back to this whole idea of
adaptation biologically speaking it
doesn't apply to individuals who changed
their behavior it has to be a more
widely adopted behavior a whole group
created a new behavioral structure in
order to survive and I think that part
of the definition is key
because we don't know how many
whisperers there are Lydia said ten
clearly a lie there's got to be more
we've seen entire herds of them shifting
unnaturally they might as well all be
whisperers in our eyes right now
in fact the whispers could be so good at
blending then there might already be
whisperers embedded in these communities
and for me that's what makes the second
half of season nine so exciting as we
head toward the finale which I'm
guessing will be the fair event that the
season keeps bringing up Connor graders
know why this Fair is such a big deal I
won't spoil it here I just love the way
that they're setting up the whispers as
a mystery in a way that will expose how
vulnerable these characters really are
what you're supporting characters do you
think could be a surprise whisper one of
these newcomers Tammy Rose is that why
she was so anxious to execute Lydia
maybe the keep her silent comment down
below with your thoughts now thanks to
Philo I'm gonna be able to break down
the next few episodes of The Walking
Dead and these videos will come out on a
Tuesday or Wednesday after the episode
airs but you can help us continue to do
this by checking out Philo Hook or
sponsor this video Philo is a streaming
service with over 50 channels including
AMC and it's really the easiest way to
watch The Walking Dead I've been using
to catch up on all the past Walking Dead
episodes and shows like better call Saul
and there's unlimited recordings so that
you can save as many shows as you want
Philo's available on Apple TV Roku
Android iOS and fire TV it's simple and
affordable only $20 a month for all this
content you can essentially save $100 a
month on your stupid cable bill and all
you cord cutters know that AMC shows
ain't exactly to find without a cable
package so Philo is your best solution
to stay cord free and commitment free
just visit www.spmtips.com or contact a
vas and subscribe to this channel and
subscribe to our podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts thank you for
watching and I know it's sad Jesus is
dead but hey maybe he'll resurrect under
a dumpster somewhere it's happened
before
come on let's go check under all the
dumpsters
[Music]